[Música]
en el tiempo
el tiempo es una palabra que vamos a
escuchar mucho en esta plática se les
preguntará para ti qué es el tiempo que
responder y has vamos a averiguarlo
por ejemplo para usted que es el tiempo
al señor el tiempo es relativo el tiempo
se ha afectado por las leyes de la
física es un buen concepto por ejemplo
para ti que es el templo para ella el
tiempo no existe el tiempo está sólo en
nuestra mente es un buen concepto
también el diccionario define al tiempo
como un intervalo en el que sucede una
acción o se realiza un acontecimiento
el concepto que a mí me gusta el tiempo
es decir que el tiempo es una
herramienta una herramienta creada por
los primeros seres pensantes para poder
comprender los cambios constantes que
sucedían a sus alrededores cambios tales
como el día y la noche las estaciones
del año las etapas de la luna por
mencionar algunos de los primeros usos
que se lleva el tiempo fue la
agricultura saber cuándo sembrar cuándo
no sembrar y cuándo recoger la cosecha
con el paso de los años el tiempo se fue
definiendo se fue haciendo más
específico
ahora tenemos años meses semanas días
horas minutos y segundos
esto nos ayuda y nos facilita para poder
medir calcular y administrar el tiempo y
es precisamente esto último lo que les
vengo hablar la administración del
tiempo
antes de continuar quiero mencionar que
estas pláticas de télex están enfocadas
hacia la educación y yo soy un fiel
creyente de que la educación no sólo
parte del aula sino que es nuestra
curiosidad y nuestra imaginación las
fuentes de aprendizaje más grandes que
tenemos lamentablemente el tiempo que
podría aprovecharse para desarrollar
habilidades generar talentos o aprender
algo nuevo se malgasta o no se aprovecha
al máximo
para dar un poco de datos sabemos es el
instituto mexicano para la
competitividad que existe solamente un
5% de personas en el país que dominan el
idioma inglés
esto es una cantidad insignificante sin
consideramos que es el idioma universal
otro dato gracias al periodista ricardo
garcía s el promedio de lectura por
mexicano al año es de 85 páginas voy a
repetir el promedio de lectura por
mexicano al año es de 85 páginas no
quiere decir que cada mexicano lee sus
85 páginas sino no quiere decir por cada
mexicano que lee 10 libros en un año
existen otros 50 que no tocan un libro
otro dato gracias a la organización para
la cooperación y el desarrollo económico
es que hay un 21% de jóvenes ninis en el
país
estos datos junto con otros nos dan a
entender que tenemos una gran área
oportunidad para el desarrollo
intelectual y de habilidades
yo considero que una de las principales
razones por las cuales tenemos estos
datos tan alarmantes es la falta de
motivación y la mala organización aunque
muchas veces no es que no se esté
motivado es que no te sabes administrar
hace tres años yo me encontraba en una
situación muy similar en la cual no era
mi falta de motivación la cual no me
permitía poder alcanzar mis objetivos o
algunos sueños sino que simplemente no
sabía cómo administrar me
en este tiempo yo sufría de una
enfermedad una enfermedad muy grave y
muy seria que afecta a miles si no es
que a millones de personas la
procrastinación que la procrastinación
es el arte de posponer las cosas porque
es un arte no cualquiera lo domina años
de práctica se requieren
un pocos tenedor te va a ser una frase
famosa es que no es que yo no me sepa
administrar es que yo funciono mejor
bajo presión
y a veces es cierto el problema es que
hay una cierta cantidad de cosas que
tienen una fecha límite que tienen un
tiempo de entrega y cuando ese tiempo se
va acabando entre el pánico el estrés y
por alguna otra razón sacan adelante lo
que tienen que hacer el problema radica
en las cosas que no tienen un tiempo
límite que tal vez nadie te va a revisar
solamente tú esas cosas que parecen no
tan urgentes o importantes se pueden
llegar a posponer toda una vida ahí
radica el problema
como les mencionaba yo hace tres años
sufrí de esta enfermedad y me afectó
tanto que llegué a tomar la drástica
decisión de volver a empezar mi carrera
dejando de lado mis amistades
reiniciarla porque sabía que le estaba
haciendo mal que podría haberle hecho
mejor
eso me sirvió mucho para poder sentarme
y pensar
y va a ser diferente que va a cambiar en
dónde está el error porque si no hacía
algo no hacer lo mismo habría sido
inútil darme de baja
recuerdo un día que está en la
computadora pasión en internet
y encontré un artículo de los intervalos
de descanso
estos son los intervalos que usan los
atletas o los deportistas para agarrar
aire tomar agua estirarse
esto lo hacen con motivo para evitar
lesiones y mejorar el rendimiento físico
me llamó la atención me puse meter un
poco más y me di cuenta que la mente que
el cerebro funciona de manera muy
similar y si pasamos largos periodos de
tiempo haciendo actividades en las
cuales no tenemos un hábito que pueden
llegar a verse tediosas aburridas como
una obligación el resultado de esta
actividad es poco satisfactorio y si es
posible la posponemos o incluso la
omitimos
partiendo de esta información y se
desarrolló de una estrategia
se me ocurrió organizar mi tiempo libre
de 15 minutos en 15 minutos como muy
sencillo yo tomaba 15 minutos para
descansar para ver la televisión serme
celular o que yo quisiera sonaba la
alarma
yo me despertaba le pone a ser algo
productivo ya se hace los pendientes de
la escuela o del hogar que eran mis dos
principales objetivos sacar la escuela
la casa
cuál fue mi sorpresa darme cuenta que
mis objetivos académicos empezaban a
terminarse en tiempo y forma de una
manera más fácil y satisfactoria al
igual que los pendientes del lugar me di
cuenta de todo el tiempo libre que
tenían mis manos
después opté sabiendo esto de agregarle
más y más cosas a mi día por ejemplo
quise sacar el hábito de la lectura y le
agregué 15 minutos de lectura mi día
pase de no haber leído dos o tres libros
en toda mi vida a más de veinte en dos
años
después quise dominar el idioma inglés
le agregué 15 minutos estudia el idioma
en internet a mi día el día de hoy no
solamente mi dominio inglés es mucho
mayor sino que estoy avanzando en mi
tercer idioma
así como esto empecé a agregar las cosas
estudiar música hacer ejercicio estudiar
economía incluso en una plática de
atleta al día
todas estas cosas son cosas que ya no me
imagino mi día a día sin tener las cosas
que ya son muy parte de mí
como todos los procesos
tú quiere evolucionando tú que irse
adaptando
el primer cambio que tuvo fue que empecé
a anotar todos los pendientes del día en
un cuaderno rápidamente se empezó a
saturar mi día y me di cuenta que
solamente la mitad de mi día usarlo para
aprovecharlo en cosas número estaba
empecé a quitar un poco la regla de 15 y
15 me dedicaba media hora 40 minutos una
hora o hasta más en que constaba en que
me sintiera cansado me sintiera
desenfocado porque simplemente sentía
ganas de descansar después descanso a
mis 15 minutos y le seguía
el siguiente cambio fue cuando me di
cuenta que no que estuviera mal leer
estudiar hacer ejercicio y demás sino
que eran cosas que por sí solas tal vez
no me iban a llevar a ningún lado estaba
buscando algo más trascendental algo más
de largo plazo en mi vida
hizo un plan anual quiero hacer en este
año que quiero aprender que quiero tener
a lo largo de este año
después de tener este plan es un plan
mensual
y voy a hacer este mes para poder
avanzar lea este plan anual luego que
voy a hacer esta semana para el plan
mensual y que lo hace el día de hoy
aparte de la lista de cosas que gusto
por hacer para seguir avanzando en este
plan general
[Música]
el último paso el último cambio con el
que me estoy enfrentando ahorita es me
quiero es hacer del cronómetro quiero
que estas acciones que lo que todo lo
que haga sea algo más natural yo
considero que los 15 minutos fue algo
que me dio disciplina la suficiente para
poder enfrentarme a la procrastinación
y esta disciplina es un medio pero el
fin al que quiero llegar
son los hábitos formarme hábitos y sin
importar que yale y mis dos horas de la
semana tengo ganas de leer leo sin
importar qué voy a hacer ejercicio
mañana no no debería hacer ejercicio hoy
lo haga porque gusto de hacerlo y que a
pesar de que tenga esta libertad pueda
sacar todos mis planes de mis pendientes
la idea de esta plática es contarles una
historia
y mostrarles todo lo que cambió en estos
tres años y cómo fue lo que desencadenó
todos estos cambios no solamente el
aprender a administrar mi tiempo ese
pequeño cambio de 15 minutos
en este punto puede que muchos estén
pensando es que yo no tengo tiempo libre
yo no tengo el tiempo libre para poder
hacer esas cosas
así que les voy a dar a todos un regalo
el día tiene 24 horas de las cuales se
debe un aproximado de 7 dejando 119
horas a la semana
en promedio se trabaja o se estudian 50
a 60 horas dejando 59 horas a la semana
59 horas para lo que tú quieras yo creo
que es tiempo suficiente
incluso si en este momento sigues
pensando no es cierto yo no tengo ni
cinco horas libre a la semana yo te
diría de verdad
en serio
y si sigues firme en esta idea podría
deducir dos cosas la primera que esto es
un rezago de que no supiste a necesitar
tu tiempo en el pasado y por eso se está
cargando la mano y la segunda que lo que
estás viviendo es una etapa es un
proceso porque te puedo asegurar que ni
tú ni nadie desea tener solamente cinco
horas a la semana para él
este cambio de mentalidad
los objetivos algunos sueños parecen muy
difíciles o incluso hasta imposibles
imposibles hasta que realmente aprendes
a administrar tu tiempo
el tiempo se acaba
el tiempo no se detiene
el tiempo no se regala ni retrocede
el tiempo puede ser tu peor enemigo
o tu mejor aliado muchas gracias
[Aplausos]